like what have kids taught you about you
um that i need to work on patients
they want your attention and you just
gotta have a lot of patience because at
some point they're definitely not gonna
be there they're not gonna be as
interested in you as they are is that
why you're making a beer for patients
definitely part of the reasons
what's it going to be called right now
uh gratis what's that like thank you of
some sort uh it's latin
oh latin that's so funny the name of my
wine is somnium which is a latin word
which means dream really look at us
being all multicultural and ancient in
our languages
like that's a sign i'm on the right
track wow yeah me too
hey everybody welcome to the pretty
intense podcast thank you for tuning in
i really appreciate it you tuning in
helps me be able to keep doing this
because i truly love talking to people
and i love sharing all these experiences
with you guys so thanks today is jay
cutler and i was so stoked to get jay
cutler he was a former chicago bears
quarterback he's lived quite the life
like afterwards he was on a reality show
started his own podcast now so when his
career was over it wasn't over over for
him took a little siesta for a year like
most of us athletes do and we're done
with our sport but i'm excited for you
to hear this interview it takes some
twists and turns that i just totally
didn't expect to happen but you know we
kicked off by talking about his kids
talking about football and then it got
into some crazy fun stuff about aliens
and reality and
moon landings and then we went into
health and things that he's tried and
things that he might want to try a lot
of fun stuff in this interview so i
think you'll come away feeling like jay
is a pretty interesting guy i sure do if
you like what you hear today and you
like any of these podcasts please hit
the subscribe button i would really
appreciate it this shows that the show
is doing its thing and that you're
interested you know you have children
three children
i do have children nine seven and six
third grade
uh second grade kindergarten
so uh
there are a handful then
it's it's getting easier it's getting
better like the boys
it just depends if the boys kind of team
up
and they do their own thing then
sailor's little girl like i can play
with her
if jackson teams up with sailor
then i mean all hell breaks loose
there's no telling what they're getting
into which one's the wildest
jacks in the middle by far
he's
second grade
seven years old
and he's uh he's wide open he's all over
the place
what's your daughter like
sometimes she can be absolutely just
hate me like this morning she came down
super sweet walked over she let me pick
her up
held her for you know like 30 seconds
other days like she'll come down and
break through school and just
look at me and like ah and just walk
away some days like she'll cuddle up on
the couch and watch tv other days she's
like get away from me don't touch me
some days she's like i can brush her
hair other days other weeks like she'll
be like don't you can't touch my hair
for a week
can you braid though i can braid hair
yes
i can't braid hair
um she i mean it's
i mean what if she's six years old
she's probably gonna let me do it twice
in her entire life
oh
yeah so she's she goes hot and cold on
you oh dad
very hot and cold
i used to be like the only
guy that she would ever want to be
around but she's getting better now i
mean even
my brother-in-law like i mean the people
like she just did not like some of my
best friends like she would not she
wouldn't say hi to him much less look at
them but she's gotten better i mean
kindergarten's been good for her
um yeah sometimes that socialization my
sister has three girls
and uh the middle one um they're like
what are they now
seven five and two and um the middle one
had a hard time with school going to
school
didn't like it
cried and now she's okay like sometimes
school you know can really help
help a kid out it does so then there's
other stuff like you learn a bunch of
really really ridiculous stuff as the
years goes on but
socializing is important
yeah it is important i mean it's been
good for so so
wanted to go to school um she loves it
uh but i think just being around
other guys kids her age boys her age has
kind of helped her out a lot but like
she loves going to school
jackson i mean he only goes to school
just because he wants to socialize like
he's
he's the kid who like gets in trouble at
lunch because he's like walking around
to every single table
that's the only problems that we have
with with that one he's he he treats
school as kind of a
it's basically
every class is recess and let's just
have fun and just hang out and talk
social butterfly
um what's uh like being a single dad man
that must be
it must be i'm guessing you're a single
dad right now i am i am
i am it's uh
it's difficult um you know i think what
i've learned is you have to be you have
to be very organized and i have help you
know i've got some people that um help
me out a lot and do some things for me
uh but you have to be really really
organized or you know you just can't do
it because
you know you have to make lunch you have
to make dinner you have to
you know get them ready you've gotta you
know on wednesdays we've got gymnastics
and we have basketball so
um you know you kind of have to plan
your week out because we're seven on
seven off so
seven days of on is is is pretty pretty
intense
what's your like your plate what does it
have on it it's got
taking care of the kids and then what
else
like what are your main projects
podcasts and the podcast which i know
you have obviously the podcast and then
um working with some guys here in town
with
uh out like outsider.com and then
there's an on three.com company
um and then where i think we're kind of
we're in the early stages of develop
developing a beer
that we kind of want to push out here in
nashville so some some fun stuff but i
mean nothing that
nothing that takes up too much time so
that those seven days i have the kids
that i can't be there and you know kind
of work around their schedule so like
when they're at school like i'll make
breakfast make their lunches and then
you know take them to school and then
i'm able to come in here to the office
maybe do rip off a couple podcasts work
on some stuff for the beer work on some
stuff for some of this other other
things i want to do um and then be back
home by the time the bus gets there and
you know have dinner made and
be able to kind of be there help with
homework and then get them to sleep are
you smarter than a fifth grader
not sure yet i've sort of been a third
grader so
that's good enough right now but
camden's camden he's he's our oldest and
he's he's pretty smart um you know he's
do you know about like the new math
situation i would probably struggle with
third grade math okay probably fifth
grade i mean i just did not like math it
wasn't my thing numbers i see numbers in
my brain just like it's like some sort
of short circuiting happens and i just
does not compute well how they're doing
it now is
like you literally need like a whole
sheet of paper for like one problem like
they're they're it's all graphed out and
it's
it's difficult
it's difficult
so i'm learning i'm also learning
how to multiply with the new math along
with my third grader so that's fine
does that help you in your life
not one bit at all
i just think there's so much stuff that
doesn't get used
95 of it
at best
what should they be learning
i don't know i mean i think you look at
school i think it's basically like how
to socialize and
be around people i mean that's that's a
lot of it like look you know unless
you're going to be a lawyer or a
mathematician or a doctor like
higher education isn't really probably
necessary
and then you know you're looking at
school debt and
you know all that stuff
you know we allow a 18 year old to take
out a hundred thousand dollar loan
for college but
you know they can't get a house when
they're done so it's it's it's all kind
of backwards i'm not i don't know the
answer so
i feel like and i don't have kids um
but i feel like like parents
relationships and children kind of are
the most triggering relationships and
that such an area for growth is being
able to
deal with those and like recognize what
comes out so
what
like what have kids taught you about you
um that i need to work on patients
they want your attention and you just
gotta have a lot of patience because at
some point they're they're definitely
not gonna be there they're not gonna be
as interested in you as they are is that
why you're making a beer for patients
that is good um
definitely part of the reasons they're
uh i think like with the salsa world and
stuff right now like beer is just kind
of getting the
the shaft here so i think there's a
there's a market here for like a a beer
that's a little bit above but like a
little bit above miller light but it's
not a craft beer
tell me more about it i've had i had a
summer in chicago where i drank a
shitload of goose island and then i was
like that was too much belgian beer for
me i should stick with wine because
i do think you gain a little more weight
with beer or at least i did that summer
oh there's no doubt there's no doubt
what kind of beer is it
so it's going to be like american it's
an amer american lager but
um
there's this german type of brewing
process he only uses four ingredients
so it's not going to be as watered down
like a bud light or milder life but we
don't want to get into the heavy
ipa or belgian craft craft heavy beer so
it's a it's a drinkable beer you can
have it um at a tailgate you can have it
on a boat you can have it in the middle
of winter you can drink it with food um
so we're just kind of working on it
what's it gonna be called right now
uh gratis
gratis what's that like thank you of
some sort in german
uh it's latin
oh latin that's so funny the name of my
wine is somnium which is a latin word
which means dream really look at us
being all multicultural and ancient in
our languages
like that's a sign i'm on the right
track wow yeah me too
so speaking of football um dude what a
weekend of football unbelievable
unbelievable some of the best games i've
seen in years
yeah
i mean that game i mean the kansas city
game uh was
unreal i mean my dad data text means
like best game i've ever seen
it might like it's gonna go down as one
of the top 10 games of all time without
a doubt
i mean if that was a if that was a
division after championship game like it
would be top five
but those dudes can flat out play oh i
mean how old's josh allen
this is like his third year maybe fourth
year i mean the new guard is coming joe
burrow josh josh allen patrick um
herbert yeah no i mean some of these
other rookies might pop up i mean
there's some dudes that can just
play football there's no defense and i'm
not sure but with patrick and josh like
they move around so well
i mean josh is like his own running he's
like a running back as well he's a
monster he's huge
so you either run the ball with him or
you play zone and then he's going to
throw the ball but if you blitz him and
you don't get home he's just going to
make bigger plays and patrick's the same
and they got really good coaches i feel
like you know those
they got got great head coaches they've
got good uh offensive coordinators
they've got talent i think they've done
a good job of getting talent around josh
over the years if they give them one
more stud um they're going to be right
there
in racing there's kind of like a the
question of car or driver
yeah so
um what's the in in sort of football
language what's the difference between
like team and coach how big of a role
like if you if you have a great team and
a shitty coach
versus a great coach and an average team
i mean because i don't feel like you
know there's nobody in the nfl that's
like that's anything other than average
at the worst
yeah true
sure kind of like racing it's not like
you have some terrible driver with uh
like everybody can do it so we're
working with like average
to great so what's more important do you
think
coach or do you think the team you know
for me as a quarterback like the
offensive coordinator was vital to me i
thought
like you know that's
calling plays to me is like an art form
like you know you've got to get in the
flow you've got to kind of guess what
they're going to play
um you know you can't just look at your
sheet and be like all right let's just
go with this this and this and see what
happens like there's a
there's a there's a delicacy there that
like a finesse so is it the offensive
coordinator that's calling more of the
calls than the coach is he telling the
coach what to put what to run
like most teams head coach
very few teams head coach actually call
the place you know kyle shanahan does
mcveigh does
read you know reed does for kc that just
goes through a different guy
um but most head coaches
have a defensive coordinator and an
offensive coordinator that will call the
play separately
and the head coach will hear him but he
doesn't have any say in what's being
called
so like that for me that offensive
coordinator was i mean he made it break
me
and the team
so you know if he called if he calls you
know a shitty play then you know
you
maybe maybe sometimes you can get out of
it sometimes you have to run it and you
just you have to take the loss so
but with that's being said i'm sure it's
like this in race car driving like
there's
there's so many i guess that would be
like that would be the car for you
yeah so like there's probably only like
there's probably there's only a handful
of
amazing offensive coordinators in nfl
exactly racecars there's probably only a
handful of you know amazing cars out
there yeah yeah yeah i could probably
interject and add like we could probably
add a third element perhaps of like crew
chief or something like that but
but you know so okay so
that would be like your gm and yeah
like he would be the one that drafting
the players and like he's like your
third element like if he sucks too
you're not gonna get any good players so
how far out is a gm thinking like does a
gm go into the draft every year and
think this year or are they almost
always playing the long-term chess game
they they do both they have to do both
and and they have to do like free agents
and the current team so
you know most of the time like you're
gonna have there there's gonna be a try
out like every monday or tuesday of new
guys that they kind of are just bringing
in and they'll work them out
you know there's a practice squad guys
that will kind of trade in and out
there's the bottom like
bottom five percent of the roster about
three percent of the roster is kind of
always evolving
oh what a shitty position to be in to be
honest
i mean like where you live and
i feel bad for some you know as you get
older like you feel bad for those guys
like you get you get a kid in and you
know he's 25 he's married and like this
is like his ninth team he's you know
busting his butt to make the team it's
just like
it's a it's a brutal business
hmm yeah yeah uh okay what about within
the team as far as like what's the most
important within the team from your
perspective you've got
quarterback
wide receivers like running backs tight
end
teams defense like what what's the
what's the what's the rank of like if
you're to build your team you start with
and go down quarterback
you know yeah i mean if you look at
you know the four teams in like they get
they got dudes that can that that can
play football
um and consistently like over time like
you have to have a quarterback that can
play
i think after that if you if you have
your quarterback um
you got to get your offensive line
yeah
you know you've gotta you gotta be able
to block you've gotta be able to protect
these guys i mean these guys ever all
these guys are getting a little bit more
um mobile they can move around like the
days of
you know a damn marino or you know even
a joe montana or tom brady just sitting
in the pocket
yeah
you know being almost statue like it's
kind of it's kind of it's not happening
anymore it's going away so that helps
because of the defense is that because
the defenses are evolving well i think
it's because of high school and college
they're running different systems you
know they're
they're that that that game has changed
so these guys are a lot more athletic
than they used to be
damn so then i think after that you guys
i think a lot of the nfl starts up front
d-line and o-line is is if you got if
you can rush the passer
and protect it or protect the pastor
like you're gonna be
you're gonna be right there you need
like one at every level on defense so
you need a defensive lineman you need a
badass linebacker and then maybe a
corner or a safety and then you need to
fill in your gaps
do you like watching football now that
you're done
you know i didn't like the first year i
was out like i was like
i mean i just wasn't interested in it
and i you know i didn't know what i was
gonna do when i was done either so i
took a break didn't watch it and then as
the boys got a little bit older now
they're just flat out obsessed so okay
well who are their teams
tell me it's the bears that'll be
hilarious um cam likes the bear i mean
the problem and that's another problem
with i think to today's kids is you know
we have direct tv so like we have that
sunday ticket package so like all the
games yeah they're on the internet they
know
every player
and so like
he was a san diego chargers fan because
he loved herbert and then last night
like he's screaming about casey
loves patrick mahomes i'm like bro like
you're turning into a band like a fan
like this is i mean he busted in the
room at six o'clock he was like you can
you six guys this morning he was like
can you believe that game because we and
jackson just watched the highlights at
the end
and i was like and that was a good one i
go so you uh casey fan he goes love
patrick
i'm like you're i don't know how i feel
about it but i mean i'm glad he enjoys
it but it's still you know whenever
whenever i was growing up i mean i grew
up in soda indiana and you know
all we had was the bears games
like that was your one game that you got
to watch and then you know i think that
you got monday night game and stuff but
like you didn't have the opportunity to
watch
nine games in one day i i didn't know
that about you so were you
stoked to play for the bears um yeah i
was excited
i was excited um because i grew up in
southern indiana and then all my
family's from northern indiana like uh
alfredo
chester right outside of gary so
basically chicago let's just call
chicago exactly so they were everyone
was excited you know we had a bunch of
people at every game so it was fun
so you didn't know what the hell you
were gonna do when you were tired what
did you like what were your interests
i'm guessing you always liked hunting
right yeah i always liked hunting um you
know but like
it's like what are we like what am i
gonna do with that like do it the
hunting show or do i mean i didn't know
i mean yeah there's nothing really did
my nascar days when i would go into the
hauler
and uh the tv would be on and gac would
be on
great american country and they had of
course some hunting shows in there too
and i was just like wow this is this is
the most boring thing i've ever seen
you know so i did i did a ton of hunting
just because like i had to fall off like
that was the first
like when i first got out i was like you
know i just want to do nothing this fall
because i've been you know
doing two days in august since i've been
like five
so
um and then after that you know we were
i was doing the reality show with uh
kristen
um
for e so we did that for
a year and a half maybe and then
i was just like something's gonna happen
like it's there's no rush like i was 35
years old 36 years old so so i was gonna
ask like why you're doing a podcast but
it sounds like the answer is you're
bored
it i was yeah i mean i was bored but i
mean i either i have enjoy i've enjoyed
it like talking to people and uh they're
like let's just concentrate on football
i was like i'll do a couple football
guests but then i'm going off the rails
here like this is the only way i want to
do this like just to talk to
interesting people that you know i hear
about that i i'm interested in and
things that i'm interested in and like
let's learn some stuff and let's have
some fun with it so i've definitely
enjoyed that part of it for sure
yeah i have the same i mean my racing
podcast with those drivers they do
really well yeah people love that stuff
but
that's not my
driving force or our main interest so
what kind of like when you start getting
guests like what's the sort of brackets
you know like i love science and
spirituality you know that kind of stuff
so what were your first kind of get
guests
i mean i had a list of like 200 people
and it was it was so
it was so bizarre it was all over the
place it's like we're just kind of
trying to
pick through and see who we can get like
you know i had a guy
on that um
he loves bigfoots like he's he's got a
bigfoot museum in california so like he
came on and talked you know i think
we've got an alien some alien people
coming on in in a month or so so
aliens oh yeah okay okay let's go
you know i you know i messed up because
i played uh
i played golf with uh donald trump going
into it i was like you need to ask
the former president like about aliens
is there anything you can tell and we
got
i just forgot forgot to ask him and so
like afterwards i was like that's like
my biggest regret i didn't know
one thing about aliens
jay's lifelong biggest regret is not
asking donald trump former president
about aliens well what would you want to
know like what would what would you be
really
what are you curious about that you
think man i somebody's got to know this
well i'd be like hey like listen i get
that this a lot of this stuff is top
secret and everything area fits in
whatever it is is there anything that
you can tell me
anything
our aliens are you know do we what do we
know about aliens that you know everyone
else you know have we do we have any
alien spacecrafts in our possessions
somewhere
you know
did we really go to the moon
you know
all kinds of stuff
like i didn't tell you anything
i did a poll on that did we go to the
moon and the results were 70 said we did
and 30 said we didn't and i was actually
like that's not bad yeah
yeah meaning like i don't think we did
but do you think we did
you don't think we did
no
i don't know man i mean
i mean how what year was that i don't
know i wasn't born
60s 50s 60s
i mean it's
to say we had that technology and then
we just lost it is makes makes no sense
and it just seems like we're just now
kind of figuring out how to
fly spacecrafts and uh with spacex and
everything like just they're just now
kind of
hammering this down
but in 1960 we were able to
hop up there and get out and walk around
also make a phone call from the moon
i mean my phone barely works now i mean
i can be in my you know condo downtown
chicago at the top of the building in
the middle of it all and i'm like i it
doesn't work what's the problem here but
yet the moon no problem full bars
i mean there's a whole lot of reasons
why maybe not
i mean look at that thing that landed on
the moon does that look like it should
get through the van ellen belt does that
look like i would want you'd want to be
in space in that thing
no none of those things look like that
um so i mean do you think there's aliens
definitely gotta be right
now the question is i mean there's just
no way it seems like the most arrogant
thing in the world to think that we are
the only ones yeah i just saw a clip
from it was like some old clip um of
elon musk and
uh on instagram and it was
basically talking about how
you know planet
solar you know the
universe has been around for 13.8
billion years
earth for four and a half billion years
and in a half a million years the sun
will get so big that it will kind of
evaporate the oceans and life won't be
sustainable
and so how many planets are there that
have had life that just go extinct
because
they don't get off the planet and they
don't figure out another way and he's
like prep i think many
i don't know i just recently read this
book it's like it's like it's like
six numbers or seven numbers and it
basically talks about like the big bang
theory
like there's like these six numbers that
are so
long
that they all had to coincide at exactly
the right time for the big bang theory
to happen and for us to create life so
like these are like you know
physicists and you know quantum physics
like some of the
top minds in the world
who
who typically
you know
don't believe in god don't believe you
know they live in big big bang theory
like that's how they they have to see
you know
it mapped out it worked out numbers-wise
yeah and these guys are saying that
there's
the numbers are so great it couldn't
have happened
i've seen that many times i i'm friends
with uh
a scientist named nasim harmine and he's
brilliant
and the way that he talks about um
the probability of humans even being
here just and how everything happened
the way it did and that we exist it's
just it's not there's not it's
essentially not a chance
so what are we yeah what's happening
yeah
i don't know
so have you ever thought about the fact
that there are like aliens already here
inner earth theory
they're already on earth
here maybe they shape-shift
maybe they're kind of like look
human-ish you know those people that
kind of look like aliens
where are you on reincarnation
um
for i think for sure i think it's the
only thing that explains old soul new
soul like you just meet people and you
can meet a five-year-old and be like wow
you're like
deep
how'd this happen or mature
and then you can meet a 45 year old and
be and think
you're just a young soul aren't you
just like to play don't you
you know i mean that's and i also think
that um
i believe
in like the akashic records have you
ever have you ever had your akashic
records right what's that
so the akashic records is
um it's basically like the field of
energy the field the field beyond us
and that everything is connected and
that in other dimensions that all
timelines exist simultaneously and that
time and space don't exist
so
there's sort of like a frequency we can
achieve where we can access these
records
and it's basically just the history
of everything it's everything that's
ever happened and probabilities of what
could happen
and
so yeah i mean it's kind of fascinating
so yeah i don't know do you believe in
reincarnation past lives
you know
it makes a lot of sense to me and i read
that i read another book a guy um so he
was hypnotizing
one of his patients and she just started
i mean vividly started talking about
this this past life
and
you know he's that you know he got her
out of it and talked to her about it
and he was like hey do you mind if i
start recording this
and she's like no problem and he he's
written like five books off after after
podcast i'll i'll figure it out um
but that's it that's his thing he
hypnotizes people and they go back and
they talk about all the and you know
someone might have um like neck pain
and
they'll be like you know you you were
you were killed and you know they
stabbed you in the neck or something of
your back or your knee
um and then he basically got so involved
with it he was talking like to the
masters
and they were telling him that you know
you have to you have to learn something
in this life for you to kind of keep
graduating
and going forward and you're eventually
going to
achieve this you know this level where
you're you know you don't go back to
earth but you're in this in this
different universe and yes
have you ever heard of dolores cannon
no
okay you should definitely look up
dolores cannon on youtube and watch her
videos she's an old old lady in these
videos she's passed since she's she was
in her 80s in these videos she might
have died 10 years ago or so and she did
hypnotherapy and when she she would go
deep into the subconscious and she
thought what she was going to get
was she thought she was going to get
past lives a lot of times but what she
ended up getting was people going to
other solar systems and planets and all
kinds of crazy stuff she has tons of
books called convoluted universe the
three waves of volunteers i was just
having a conversation this weekend with
some girls about uh the waves of
volunteers have you heard about the
three waves of volunteers
it's um like the original waves of
volunteers that came and signed up for
this earth earth school as it's called
by dolores
is uh the people that didn't want to be
here they felt like they they were the
first ones they they really didn't want
to do it didn't want to be here to help
raise the frequency and you know
shift the dna um
and then the second wave uh they like
hold the frequency so they don't even
have to do anything just walking around
they can they can tune frequencies of
other people
but the problem is they don't want to be
around people they like to kind of be on
their own and then the third wave is
like the crystal children and they
already have the upgraded dna they're
already there
um but they're young and so that's the
third wave and that apparently there's
some like critical mass that's finally
been achieved now where there's enough
people to help shift the frequency to
like transcend into the new earth she
talks about new earth a lot have you
heard about new earth
um a little bit i mean i don't do you
so right now she's saying that the
frequency has been changed
yeah i mean this is all her talks like
from when she was still alive but that
there's enough and that it's shifting
it's happening
the the transition is
is travelling into the minds i'm not
that optimistic about
people at this point unfortunately
maybe that's sad
i mean there's a lot to be bummed about
there's a lot to look at and think it's
worse than ever but
on the other side of it there's
potential that it's better than ever
that's true i mean i think if you look
at the look at the world now compared to
where it was you know
a hundred years ago it's like we've come
extremely long way you know the
way of life and your
poverty and and health and
you know all those things are
way up there but
i don't know i guess there's just other
things we deal with
so um with all this talk are you
like is there is there a sense of
spirituality within you are you curious
about that are you is that would you
call yourself more spiritual than
religious that's kind of like the
usually the deciding factor i suppose
you know i grew up in a church i grew up
um
you know
god and jesus and
all all those things um
you know and there's still a large part
of me that it that is there
um
but there's another huge part of me that
you know i kind of went away from that
kind of came back to it
and there but there's a huge part of me
that is really curious
about you know all these other you know
not just religions but you know aliens
spirituality you know the hypnotized
reincarnation um that
so i i guess i would say i'm spiritual
but you know my background is in you
know is in that is in the church so it's
hard to say where i land on it does it
make you feel like you're blasphemous if
you say you're not really religious
no no
no did you have any experiences
sometimes that's what does it you know
there's you know you see it you think
you see an alien or you have an
experience in your sleep or
you know you have a mystical experience
sort of a transcendent moment has any of
that stuff ever happened to you no i
wish i would i think that'd be cool but
um i'm not that lucky you know there's
just so much out there for i think we're
where i land where i have a hard time
with is like you know
someone says you know you've got to
believe in x y or z period
because it's in the bible or whatever
wherever wherever you land on it like i
have a really
hard hard time with that because
you know there's
however many different religions out
there and some of them are
make a lot of sense and there's a lot of
people out there there's a lot of
smarter people than me
um
that know a lot more than me too so
i just don't like it when people are
like you know it's it's this way or
you're not going to heaven yeah i agree
well what do you teach your kids then i
mean i feel like that's the like you
know when you have kids it's one thing
to think things on your own and
yeah
you know pontificate on what you know
what's real and what's not and what
matters to you and what doesn't and it
can change right but when you have kids
you're kind of like what do you teach
them and you feel like there's got to be
some level of consistency i would think
i think they're there there can be but i
also you know i tried to you know let
them kind of navigate the waters a
little bit on their own
you know i you know being in the south
you know you look at some of these
families and you know they've got a you
know they've got a three-year-old that
is i mean already indoctrinated like
they're they're fully oh yeah you know
the church
in on god like you know jesus all the
stuff and
maybe that's right thing maybe it's not
um
i just don't want to
i just don't want my my kids to
i'm not going to tell them exactly what
to think i want them to kind of figure
some stuff out and if they come back to
that on their own and that's how they
figure it out i think that's better
than me telling my five-year-old all
right this is exactly how it is because
i don't know i don't know if that's 100
true
i mean no one does i mean you might
believe it might have faith and i think
that's that's the beauty of it but
for me to
tell them that and then you know 25
years down the road they're like hey dad
you're you're completely full of [ __ ]
that's not it
i mean it's probably definitely going to
say that at some point oh that's
something oh yeah
like you know you know i've talked to
them about they've we both have talked
about you know reincarnation we've
talked about them about you know
buddhism we talked to them about god and
jesus
like i want them to be
i guess well round is not the right word
but i just want them to kind of take in
some of this knowledge and then
figure it out as i go
well it's like having options it's kind
of like today you know if you
watch
the news and you only watch one channel
and you that like it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy of you know spin cycle of the
same information you'll never think
different so having those options means
there's you know it's you watching every
channel and being like i don't know yeah
that kind of resonates that doesn't yeah
and i also don't want them to like you
know
when they get a little bit older of some
kid says hey you know i believe x y and
z and my kids go no you're completely
wrong like i want them to be able to
have an open dialogue be like all right
well tell me more about that you know i
kind of believe this but i want to hear
what this is about
so as far as past lives do you feel like
you have any reincarnation do you feel
like you have any
thoughts or feelings or intuitive hits
on like man in a past life i was
definitely
a viking yeah uh-huh or i was some like
mayan warrior
after i read all those books i was like
i want to go and get hypnotized and do
this but i don't think i can be
hypnotized i think i'm one of those
people have you done it i've never been
hypnotized but
i mean you have to be willing you know i
i think you have to be willing to and by
when i say that it's like you know there
can be a lot of experiences you have
that where you transcend into a
different space but you have to believe
it's possible but you have to be willing
and open like you have to believe it's
possible you know and want to
yeah i think you also have to believe
that i think a part of you has to
believe that you were
you definitely had past lives too
yeah i mean i think that's part of it i
mean because if you didn't have a past
life and you're like i'm doing a past
life regression i'm getting hypnotized
you're like this is so stupid and
because your energy matters your
frequency matters i mean i've seen like
uh like you know the aura people they
take a picture and then they tell you
about all that stuff like
and and i've also been to i don't know
if there's a minor i don't know what his
exact title was but like i go into those
things like
who was it did you see somebody you saw
somebody for something
yeah here i've seen somebody here in
town and then there's i saw somebody in
chicago
like a psychic reader or like an oral
reader both i've seen i've seen both
okay
and but i go into those things like
i say nothing like i'm not telling you
anything like i'm like i'm measuring my
words i'm i'm being short as possible
yeah
because there's a part of me is like all
right this is a gimmick like i'm gonna
i'm gonna give them something that
you know
they're gonna take and it's something i
wanna hear
and they're gonna they're gonna work the
system a little bit so but i mean the
the two times i've i've done it like
they've been i mean they've nailed it
do you get sketchy about like how how
early they have to know your name
because when i do it i'm like oh man how
early do they have to know my name you
know because that's gonna throw
everything off and it's not like i'm
that famous right but i'm you know it
just doesn't it doesn't take a lot of
google searching oh no exactly like i've
given like fake names before
good one why didn't i think of that yeah
just change your last name
a perpetuating thought i have which is
why i love quantum physics so much
is um and science is the question of
like what is reality do you ever think
about that
tell me more
are we
holographic in nature is this uh
simulation
are we zeros and ones
are we
you know what what where did we come
from are we aliens of some sort
like what is the nature of our reality
you know i mean one of the things
dolores says that's so crazy is she goes
you know there's a concept that's hard
but this place that we're at for this
talk right now didn't exist until you
all
came here
she's like i know that's hard to
understand but
it is hard to understand um you know but
then it's also like if you start
thinking too much about that stuff
aren't you just missing the the beauty
of this life and you're not present and
you're not just enjoying it or do you or
or can you do both i think that if
no i think knowing or or going towards
knowing
if i ever got to know which is probably
an unending
search until you die and i'm not ready
um
it would i would think there would be
a direction how to live your life right
like if you realize that this is just
like one of a thousand lives and it's
just some little increment and you are
just trying to learn the one lesson that
you left off within last life to come
back and do the next version i always
think to myself i don't want to come
back and learn this lesson next time i
don't want to have to get to this point
to do this again i'm going to do it now
and um and so things like that it helps
me to figure out how to live my life
that makes sense i like that
have you figured out what that thing is
yet no of course not
it's just intuitive thoughts like as a
man are you tapped into your body like
that's one thing that i feel like men
are a little bit not quite as
in tune with but do you get are you and
do you feel like you're intuitive do you
feel like you like know where things sit
in your body can you feel
energy
um
probably not as well as as a woman does
i mean i i feel like i listen to my gut
really well that's good yeah that's it
yeah i mean i think i i definitely do
that
um you know and just being a
professional athlete like you're i'm
you're in tune to your body and your
mind and like like i think that just
comes kind of naturally so you know i
for myself like i go with whatever my
god like you know my mind i feel like i
overthink things a lot so i'm like all
right let's just settle down like what's
my what was my first gut instinct where
am i at
let's just do that don't don't come up
with a million different scenarios of
how this could go right or how it could
go wrong and play it all out
what's your gut say do that
and there must be some stories of both
those decisions the one that you went
with to get and the one that you didn't
like because you've proven this to
yourself somehow right
i mean when i whenever whenever i left
denver i was like all right like what do
what do i want to do no
there was both sides of it there was all
this stuff i was like all right my god
like i can't play here anymore like this
is just it's just i gotta go and so
and even even when i was done with
football then too i was like all right
like you know there's
other opportunities um you know the kids
were getting a little bit older
um
you know you're getting pressure from
you know agents and and friends and
other people hey go do this go do that
um and you know i just sat with myself
and i was like all right
you know my guts i'm done like i'm just
i'm tapped out here i'm tired like
you're just
hanging up you're done
so it wasn't hard it wasn't a hard
decision or it was it was it felt clear
at least
it felt clear enough you know but i mean
it was over a week or so so i mean i
mean it was you go back and forth back
and forth back and forth um and play it
all out and
but at
the end of the day like i think you just
have to trust most people have to trust
yourself some people can't trust
themselves but i feel like i can okay
another thing that you hit on that you
said you love do you like to talk to
people about is health and i'm super
into it are you into anything cool or
crazy or different a guy have someone
showing up when we're done with these
interviews to do my first nad drip
that's exactly what i was gonna say nad
that's exactly what i was gonna say
you haven't done it i haven't done it
and the doctor i'm working with does it
like a front load so i do i'm doing five
out of ten days
okay so you're doing five days
i'm gonna do like i think i'm gonna do a
monday wednesday thursday friday monday
okay yeah i don't wanna you know i want
them to be able to get that i don't want
it to get all you know my vein and you
know
yeah um
it's
you're you're gonna hate it
oh great
you're gonna hate well maybe it just
depends like just have them go really
slow
yeah they say you can get nauseous oh
yeah
oh great
so like
it feels like
for me the first time like i've done
i've done uh i've done five days in a
row
um
and then three take a day off three days
uh i've done
my latest was i just did uh
every monday
for six weeks
okay
and i'm about probably in another month
i'll probably go back and do another
like three or four day treatment um
so i played basket i i was playing
basketball um with
kind of these older guys at a high
school down here
and like my left knee is always giving
me problems just
always has just achy and like if i jump
on it too much like it just hurts like
help
and you know sleep anxiety like stress
like all those things
after you do nad for a couple days
you'll feel like you're 20 years old
you'll sleep like a baby
your stress will be down anxiety
um
it's
your appetite your energy
uh your recovery
like workouts recovery will be through
the roof
wow
this stuff's incredible
it's incredible my understanding was
it's kind of like i thought it was about
just detoxification then it was like no
it's kind of hormonal kind of balance
like it balances you out energy like
emotionally
then it's about you know um you know not
getting so much anxiety and stress like
he you know doctor even said like colors
get brighter he's like honestly the
world kind of brightens up so it's
almost like a cellular
boost it's just like almost like you
become like you go from human to
superhuman yeah well i mean nad is in
every cell in your body so it's in the
brain so it charges up every cell so as
you get older
i mean think about whenever you're a kid
like you could you could run around for
hours on end and like
like my kids don't stop
so you know you just boost up all those
cells again and it's it's
it's incredible stuff
so have you tried anything else like i
think there's curcumin there's like all
kinds of other things have you tried any
other drips uh
no i mean i've done all like the big
chips but like
nad one is
i don't know how you could beat it
honestly i did a podcast with um
van carcillo hockey player for uh
blackhawks
and he's um
he's microdose and mushroom making a
company out of that
and i haven't
yeah and then my doctor here who does
the nad
um
he was saying that some of his
you know elite patients that are out
there killing it microdose lsd which is
scarier to me than mushrooms
yeah i mean well that's a synthetic yeah
exactly so
it's a little a little bit different
when it's a synthetic but
the world of medicine is changing
rapidly but you know lsd i think lsd was
developed as a like a truth serum drug
way back in like the 60s or something
like that yeah i think they're using it
to yeah you said like they capture
people and they just give them lsd isn't
that like mdma is that kind of all the
same stuff
no it's a little different that's molly
i think that just makes you happy that's
ecstasy i've never had that but
i'm sure it's great you're probably not
gonna go ahead and divulge all of the
things that you've tried and i don't
blame you i honestly have never had
ecstasy that's fascinating i mean i
think you should try that stuff you're
retired now you can try whatever you
want i mean i think like you said the
world of world of medicine and health
and drugs is rapidly changing and i
think uh we're learning a lot more than
we ever have before well what's next
what's next on the try it list for you
other than micro dosing psilocybin yeah
i think it's i think that's what's up
next nad and that do more of that maybe
you should just go for the hero's dose
of psilocybin first
he was we were talking about that
and he was like
because i mean
they're walking they're walking people
through this like they'll set up a room
setting gets you all geared up and stuff
and he's like listen he goes
the first couple hours might be the
worst experience of your life
and i'm like really he's like well you
have to go into it with a purpose you
got to have you know this is what i want
to accomplish and he said like the first
hour or so he said it could be could be
absolute hell
he goes but then you get you get out of
it
and he goes you know you you mentally
you'll have a breakthrough and you know
you'll see things completely different i
mean rogan talks about it all the time
think oh yeah this guy's probably into
ayahuasca then too if he's doing
ceremony stuff like that i'm sure
do you know what that is
um yes i've never done it though yeah
there's so many things out there but
there's shaman to walk you through that
stuff you do but that's what he's
talking about is like walking you
through it like creating the room
creating the space
you know giving you
giving you a safe space so that you can
let go right like i said if you want to
get into that you know if you want to
get hypnotized you got to be able to let
go like you got to feel safe you got to
be open to it do you still work out a
bunch um not as much as i used to
know you know more just kind of
stretching keeping things together like
gaining gaining muscle is not my goal
anymore by any means speaking of knees
have you tried walking backwards in that
whole new craze
no haven't heard of this oh you should
definitely look that up there's i can't
remember the doctor but i just went and
did this and uh
gabby reese you know uh the volleyball
player her and laird they're super into
fitness and health and all things and um
she took me to the beach and we went uh
we went walking backwards for a couple
of miles but it's supposed to be
incredible for your knees well it makes
sense because you're going in one
direction your entire life yeah you're
just you know you're just wearing those
muscles out so
it makes it makes makes a lot of sense
yeah i'm into it i guess
are you doing the uh
like the wim hof stuff cold tubs and
everything
my morning routine is i wake up
i red light infrared infrared yeah i uh
dry brush
i take a cold shower
and then i drink coffee
that's that's generally my morning
there's a workout in there that's a good
coffee enemas i don't know if you've
ever tried that
uh i haven't tried every part of them
though
yeah there's that take
whatever magical pills oh i take
peptides
okay you take peptides yeah what about
uh like ozone
i've heard about that
have you done it
that's also
enema form yeah uh-huh that's what i
heard i don't think i've done it enough
to get the full benefits because it's
just
you're sticking a tube
of
ozone but i mean i don't know it's just
it's maybe maybe it's too much for me
it's probably too much for you to talk
about because you're a dude and anytime
a dude talks about getting something
stuck up their butt it's really
uncomfortable
that's very true wait i gotta ask you
about the chicago days and that one time
when you were on the sideline looking
really sad and pouty in your big jacket
did you feel like you caught a lot of
flack for that well they should have
left me in the locker room
that's what should have happened i
shouldn't have been out there and i did
catch a lot for that
and like no one really protected me so
it is what it is and that's that that
was the difference in chicago and like
denver like denver mike shanahan was
there like everything went through life
like he
owned the narrative in chicago you know
they're competing papers there's there's
a lot going on so i feel like your
personality is kind of
just easy going cool do you feel like
that's why sometimes maybe it kind of
got going because you didn't there
wasn't you didn't sit i don't know i
don't remember you saying anything or i
didn't i just
i went through and i went through uh
exit exit uh physical on really game on
sunday maybe monday and then i left i
was on i never said anything for like
two or three months i wasn't even i
wasn't gonna find him like what is was
what it was um
what's the misunderstanding about jay's
personality that you think people don't
know because i don't i mean look i only
knew you as a football player
i
you know
heard opinions of people that you know
that are like now jay's cool he's a
really great guy he's super
super great guy i mean i think in
chicago we got we got the uh
you know we lost games early on
um
and then like
i got in trouble for
you know yelling at teammates and being
a little bit more fiery and then
i was like all right well i'm just gonna
not do anything and then i got gel and i
got trouble for doing that
and then it was like you know what
i'm just going to go out here and play
football and
just do my job not say [ __ ] and say as
few words as possible do my job try to
win games misconception was like i
didn't care you know i was just out
there
yeah and that was that was the farthest
thing from the truth like you know i was
working i was doing everything under the
sun to try to win these football games
you know playing her doing
everything fighting with coaches in the
in the in the in the meetings like you
know trying to improve the game plan you
know trying to get good players in there
um so i think that was the biggest
misconception that kind of pissed me off
but but i also like my personalities i'm
not going to go out there and you know
defend myself to the media over and over
and over again i was just like all right
it is what it is i'm just going to
continue as long as my teammates were
cool with me and like i was good in the
locker room i was like all right that's
the rest of it doesn't matter
i actually think that the reality show
did a good job of showing like funny
side of you and for sure yeah
absolutely i don't know how it was to do
a reality show i i think that would be
misery to me but
maybe it was fun
it wasn't bad it wasn't as bad as you
think it is um you know it's more
scripted than anything i mean when i say
scripted like they would go hey here's
our scene we need this
you guys go and figure it out
or you know or this is the goal of of
this scene you know this is what we're
talking about
go um and then you kind of say what you
want to say so it really kind of depends
on who you're if you're working with
somebody that's pretty good and is on it
it's pretty it's pretty seamless so
would you do another one then
depends on what it was about i mean i
wouldn't say no by any means um well
it's about your life dude that's what
they're always about hunting your
podcast you're hanging out with trump i
would do that no yeah i'd do that in a
heartbeat you know i wouldn't wanna i
wouldn't do stuff out of my house
um like it was before and i don't i
definitely wouldn't do a
like an intimate relationship again i
can't
um so i wouldn't do that but i mean if i
was having fun doing something about my
life hunting all the other stuff that
happens podcast
the beer i'd be in on that heartbeat
there you go you just called it in all
right who's going to the super bowl
uh kc and the rams
that'll be a good game that would be a
fun that would be a fun outcome be
really good the rams i think the rams
rams
they they have a test though the 49ers
said defense is good they're going to
run the ball
um they're gonna do all the all those
things casey
they i don't think they can be stopped
right now they're on fire
they're rolling
what do you got
yeah i think that's a good bet okay i
think that was a good game i mean as far
as far as kansas city like to come off
of that game that's a boatload of
momentum
that's a lot of energy that's a lot of
pep in your step
yeah they don't feel like they can be
stopped and i think that you know i
think that not you know i think rolling
right into the next one will really help
too i always think bye weeks are a drag
i don't know why i always feel like it
breaks the momentum oh wait suck i hate
my weeks it's just
if you're if you're doing well if you're
if you're
towards rock bottom it's like i can't
wait for the bible give me there
right
all right cool thanks jay thank you i
appreciate it
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button